hello everyone today we're playing City
skylines 2 in Early Access where we're
going to find out whether we can turn
Houston into a car-free city big thanks
to Paradox for grinting me access to the
city skylines 2 Early Access and for
sponsoring this video City skylines 2
will be out on the 24th of October so
all of you will get to play it soon
enough so here we have our beautiful
representation of Houston a beautiful
aagam of Highways parking lots and tall
towers formerly the city center
surrounded by some completely unwalkable
suburbs oh and the editors note this is
obviously a small representation of the
city would happily recreate the entire
city in cies Skylands 2 but
unfortunately I do not have access to
the IBM main frame I'm also playing on
an early pre-release version of the game
so don't worry about the occasional
visual bug or performance issues all
right so what do we do to fix this mess
as we all know one of the main sources
of Houston's problems is cars traffic is
way too high rendering entire areas of
the city unfit for human habitation
there is also induced demand the
phenomenon whereby adding more Road
capacity motivates more people to drive
making traffic worse lucky for us there
is a solution induced demand also works
backwards as it turns out whereby
reducing Road capacity motivates more
people to leave their cars at home and
look for Alternatives so here we have a
beautiful 10 Lane Highway feeding the
city let's work some reverse induced
demand Magic on it we'll start with a
slight reduction from 10 lanes to two
lanes desperate times call for desperate
Solutions luckily it's nighttime so
traffic is low Come Morning the citizens
of Houston will be in for a surprise
what do people say about it on Twitter
well nothing yet I wonder if Paradox
will keep up with the times and turn
chirper into why and when you open it
it's full of people posting far right
propaganda and deranged conspiracies and
accusing the mayor of being a 15-minute
City touting deep State Jew for wanting
to turn a street into a pedestrian Zone
the city skylines through traffic AI
actually takes time and transportation
cost into account when plotting a route
so we actually can motivate people to
get out of their cars and of course we
won't leave them without Alternatives
let's create an interchange of sorts
with a nice big roundabout straight to a
public transit terminal with some people
as for parking lots this is where we're
going to shock houstonians with the
concept of quality public transit
originally I thought Americans viewing
public transit as a dirty poor people
thing was mostly a joke until I saw this
tweet from Carla s former Trump
appointed US ambassador to Denmark I've
seen this before in Denmark middleclass
people can't afford to drive a car they
have a bike and take the train for long
trips my Embassy Driver would bike an
hour in the snow to get to work that's
the future team Biden wants for
Americans is this what you want now
obviously ambassadors cannot always
immerse themselves in local culture but
Jesus way to tell us that throughout
your four years as the ambassador to
Denmark you've only seen the country
from the backseat of the embassy SUV the
replies to this are predictably very
funny and they include one of the most
monstrous ratios I've ever seen from the
former Danish Ministry of Transport with
37,000 likes compared to the original
post 1500 like yeah Carla next time
trying to actually get to know the
country you're serving in instead of
just drinking cocktails and being driven
around for four entire years back to
Houston people are experiencing an
alternative to their car for the first
time in their Liv lives I must say the
game has some nicely detailed double
decker trains which is a welcome
improvement from the first games on the
script train Models All right so here we
go the first houstonians discovering the
concept of public transportation we have
a few cars driving in actually I think
we can expedite this process come to
think of it why have outside Road
Connections at all instead everyone can
just Pile in through the one Highway and
then Park their car by the station and
take the train into the city where
coincidentally every single street is
pedestrianized but I also don't want to
condemn people to hours of walking
across the City though most Americans
could definitely use it instead I've
built out a basic Subway and trm network
on top of the rail connection to provide
people with quick access to the rest of
the city essential Services can continue
to use pedestrian streets as regular
streets though what I like about City
skylines 2 is how service facilities
like subway Depot Rail Yards and so on
are larger than in the previous game
appropo Rail Yard this is the part where
I randomly start renting about train
related stuff welcome to the channel
have you heard of The Budapest black
grade rail line the Hungarian government
under Victor Orban is building it the
line is to serve Chinese y political
interests linking a chinese-owned Greek
Port to the rest of Europe by rail since
this rail line need to serve Chinese
interest naturally the Hungarian
government is paying for it via a
Chinese loan according to estimates the
line will return the investment to the
Hungarian government through customs
fees in 979 years now then the Budapest
bgrade line cost € 11.65 million e per
kilm as a comparison the Berlin Munich
line cost 1527 million EUR per kilm it
sounds like a pretty good deal except
the budapes bgrade line is designed for
160 km per hour and runs on almost
completely flat terrain while the Berlin
Munich line is designed for 300 kmph and
contains 20 tunnels 300 rail Bridges and
overpasses and 170 Road overpasses and a
few weeks ago construction actually
stopped on the budapes backr line there
is an issue with the European Train
control system or etcs that they want to
build there the Chinese were supposed to
build it but they can't as the European
version is far more complex than the
standard Chinese version so they
wouldn't be able to get it certified the
problem is the Chinese government will
only pay for a completed project so now
financing is basically halted on until
they can find someone who can actually
build the Train control system but
problem number two is that the Hungarian
company working alongside the Chinese is
owned by a guy called Lin mesaros he's a
former gas repairman who according to
past customers was nearing bankruptcy
just a few years ago and could barely
write down his own name on a piece of
paper now he's the richest man in
Hungary frequently seen on luxury yards
and various ruling class social
functions how did he manage this he's a
former schoolmate of Victor Orban who
needed a proxy to hide his growing
illicit wealth so Orban put this
functionally illiterate gas repairment
into the leader's chair of his Empire to
pose as its owner meanwhile the Empire
is led by a shadow managerial class from
the background as M haros can barely
read or write but in exchange for his
ACT he gets to play with the big boys
toys like Yachts luxury cards and so on
but the business Empire is also a
massive money distribution hub for
orbons allies and cronies and they need
a constant inflow of money including
from the budapes black gr Rail Project
but the Chinese money is on hold pending
the Project's completion EU money is
also on hold as orban's Government stole
too much and insists to this day that
the EU is run by Jews who are working to
destroy the white race VI M migration so
there's no money and the big Rail
Project is halted but your crew is won
their allowance how did they solve this
situation out of nowhere they announced
a complete reconstruct of hungary's most
important rail line the budapes Vienna
in like 2 weeks in advance how will it
be financed the Hungarian State Railway
has to cover it out of pocket from the
already minimal maintenance budget or
else the leadership is fired once the
surprise reconstruction was announced M
Chinese company took all their workers
and materials intended for a Budapest
backg grade line and just shipped them
to the Budapest Vienna line virtually
overnight and spontaneously started
reconstructing it this innovatively
caused complete chaos on the line where
the schedule practically ceased to exist
as a response the Austrian Railways cut
off budapes from the international
network with most rail Jets terminating
in Vienna so yeah this is what's going
on currently on the Hungarian rail
network I just wanted to share this with
you back to Paradox Houston I was
wondering why my city center wasn't
growing at all it turns out it's a bad
idea to place landmark residential
commercial and Office Buildings as they
have a monstrous capacity to absorb
demand and they take ages to to fail
once you demolish those everything
suddenly starts to grow and well to a
point anyway looks like I've actually
managed to break the game buildings on
pedestrian streets reporting no
pedestrian access all the game's
algorithms are going haywire because I
don't have a traditional Road connection
just the way I like it looking back at
the car dumping Hub I realized what the
problem was turns out all the parking
lots are full so citizens cannot
disembark and get on the trail City
skylines 2 has a far more complex
parking management system than the
previous game it was at that point that
I decided to go even further and cut the
road connection entirely and what could
go wrong so I deleted the road
connection relying solely on trains and
my population actually kept increasing
somehow at that point I've decided to
stop ignoring the text messages from
better dox telling me to stop instead of
trying to break a pre-release version of
City skylines 2 I'll wait until the 24th
of October to do so with the full
version Jokes Aside based on my first
impressions C kind has to be shaping up
to be a great game overall among others
I really like the new mixed zoning
option the new parking management the
more complex tax policies there is a lot
to do and lots of things to customize it
has much more depth and complexity out
out of the box and it will only get more
enjoyable once the community starts
modding it like they did with cies
skylines 1 it was so successful in fact
that many of cies skylines St features
were actually C skylines 1 mods
incorporated into the new release after
EA Games ruined Sim City C skylines 1
became the city Builder game doing
everything right that Sim City did wrong
now City Skyland 2 improves upon that
even shaping up to be a truly formidable
City Builder a flagship game of paradox
interactive by the way the game is
available for pre purchase already so if
you like the city Builder genre or
consider getting into it h
recommendation for you is to get it
thank you once again to Paradox for
giving me early access to the game and
for sponsoring this video and I thank
you for watching feel free to like And
subscribe and I also have a patreon if
you wish to support me making more
content I'll have a couple more videos
coming out in the near future so stay
tuned for that and I'll be seeing you on
the 24th of October release
day